مرحبا بكما ولكن اسمحوا لي اولا ان ابدا
من الحدث من ستاد البيت حيث يتواجد مجيد
وايمن واحمد مجيد اطلعنا على الاجواء هل
فتحت الابواب
نعم جلال الابواب فتحت للجماهير منذ حوالي
20 دقيقه وبالتالي الحضور الجماهير حول
الملعب بدا جلال والاستعدادات قبل ساعتين
الان تقريبا من موعد
الافتتاح الرسمي لمونديال قطر 2020 جلال
دعني سريعا ارحب همم ضيفنا خالد النعمه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اللجنه العليا الارثه
للحديث عن حفل الافتتاح تحديدا السيد خالد
مرحبا بك لحظات حاسمه بعد مسيره طويله
الثانيه 10 عاما الان اللحظه الحاسمه كيف
تشعر وما همم شكل حفل الافتتاح الذي
ينتظره الجميع
لحظات كما تفضلت همم صحيح انها حاسبه
لكنها لحظات ايضا سعيده لحظات همم مليئه
بالفخر مليئه بالحماس لاسيما ان المنتخب
القطري ايضا يلعب مباراه الاولى تاريخيه
في بطولات كاس العالم همم لحظه اي نثبت
فيها جداره هذا الملف الذي لا قام لاقى
خلال اثني عشر عاما الماضيه ولذلك يملئنا
الفخر تملئنا الثقه ايضا بيوم ناجح بحول
الله الجميع ينتظر خمسه مليارات في العالم
ينتظرون هذه اللحظه الحاسمه همم ما هي
البصمه التي
تقدمها قطر من خلال حفل الافتتاح خالد
دائما ما كانت البصمه هي البصمه العربيه
القطريه الاسلاميه الخالصه اعتقد النحافه
الافتتاح اليوم الذي سيمتد ان شاء الله
الى وقت همم جيد ومناسب لاصال الافكار من
خلال من خلال العرض موسيقي همم مرئي همم
سيحمل رسائل جميله من الوطن العربي الى
العالم الاخر الى الغرب تحديدا هذه
الرسائل ستحمل لب الرياضه وهي تفسير
الثقافات وتقريب همم يعني الشعوب اعتقد
انه سيكون حفله ان شاء الله بالمشاعر
وسيشعر به العرب يعني بدرجه اولى وايضا
سيلامس كافه عشاق المستديره بحول الله
خالد ااه بعد الحفل سيكون تحدي اخر لاول
ظهور في تاريخ الكره القطريه العنابي سوف
يسجل حضوره في كاس العالم للمره الاولى
وسيكون تاسع منتخب عربي ياخذ هذا التحدي
همم كيف تنتظر الشكل الذي سيظهر به
المنتخب القطري ومن ورائه اكثر من 60,000
مشجع قطري وعربي
بشكل عام اعتقد ان الشارع الرياض القطري
متفائل هذا المنتخب همم شارك في بطولات
بدون وجود الجماهير القطريه خلفها عن
الامان لكافه همم شارع الرياض القطري ان
يقف خلف هذا المنتخب همم نتوقع منهم
ونتمنى منهم ايضا تاديه ما يستطيعون
تقديما 110% كما يقال النتيجه في علم
الغيب لكن واكد لك ان مدرجات صادر البيت
ستغسل الجماهير القطريه التي ستقف ان شاء
الله يدا ابيات خلف العنابي الى اخره في
هذه البطوله شكرا جزيلا السيد خالد نعمه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اللجنه العليا اعرف
ان عندك شغالات كثيره بطبيعه الحال اذا
همم جلال كان هذا السيد خالد النعمه
متحدثا عن همم حفل الافتتاح والظهور الاول
للعنابي القطري اعيد واكرر بان ابواب
الملعب استاد البيت فتحت في هذه اللحظات
والجميع والجماهير بدات تدخل خاصه القطريه
من اجل مؤازره العنابي القطري في اول ظهور
له هنا في استاد البيت حيث سوف يفتتح
مونديال العرب مونديال قطر 2022 وقطر
اعيده واكرر انها الدوله الثامنه عشر التي
سوف تنظم المونديال وتعد بمونديال سيبقى
نسخه استثنائيه عالقه في ادهان الجميع
وبالتوفيق للجميع بحول الله جلال